quelles ont été vos premières pensées en
apprenant ce matin ses nouveaux
attentats terrible d'abord une grande
tristesse
et puis évidemment le sentiment que nous
avons tous que personne ne peut être
épargné ne peut se considérer
aujourd'hui comme épargné nulle part
dans le monde
aujourd'hui il n'ya d'abris contre 7
cette guerre terroriste en que cela
ajoute aux responsabilités des élus
donc vous êtes en ile de france
particulièrement bien entendu bien
entendu puisqu'on voit que les capitales
européennes sont particulièrement ciblés
la belgique c'est à quelques encablures
de la france ça arrive directement par
la gare du nord en ile de france donc
donc évidemment il ya des vases
communicants qui sont importants et puis
il faut pas se cacher la vérité tout ça
est quand même créé liée à l'arrestation
de salah abdeslam c'est-à-dire aux
attentats de paris il y à une filière
belge qui a commis déjà des attendus à
paris quels sont les points que vous
avez abordé avec le ministre de
l'intérieur je les appelais dès la
matinée dès qu'on a su dès qu'on a su la
nouvelle pour parler avec lui des
transports en ile-de-france alors les
transports en ile de france
nous avions déjà une vigilance extrême
mais il faut il ne faut pas relâcher nos
efforts et c'est vrai que dès qu'il se
passe trois semaines un mois deux mois
de calme on pourrait être tenté de
relâcher la vigilance donc il ne faut
pas relâcher la vigilance et au
contraire moi ce que je lui ai proposé
ce matin et nous allons nous revoir la
semaine prochaine pour en parler c'est
d'accélérer la mise en place d'un
certain nombre de mesures que nous avons
voté dans le cadre du bouclier de
sécurité francs signant alors ce qu'il
faut mettre en place
et bien c'est notamment un certain
nombre d'équipements de sécurité de
nouvelles technologies pour détecter par
exemple les comportements suspects par
le biais de sur les quais des gares
je voudrais aussi qu' on puisse engager
très vite et c'est un plan que j'ai
proposé ce matin la modernisation du
matériel roulant passe
là aussi alors ça va prendre plus de
temps on ya entendu c'est sur du plus
long terme il nous faut aussi de la
vidéo protection dans donc les rams à
voltaire également aujourd'hui la
rénovation des trains qu'il y aura des
portiques par exemple comme al harraz
élus les ont proposés également dont je
pense au sud de la france alors moi je
crois beaucoup beaucoup plus je crois à
deux choses je crois d'abord à des
outils de détection un peu innovant
technologique technologique et un peu
moins
voyons ce que le problème des portiques
c'est que de toute façon ils sont
impraticables en ile de france nous
avons quatre millions de personnes qui
prennent les transports en commun tous
les jours 4 millions c'est à dire qu en
ile-de-france y en a plus que sur tous
les terrains avec tous les tgv de france
entière à lorsque la vérité c'est que
vous pouvez pas mettre arctique
aujourd'hui à la gare du châtelet où
quelques sinon vous avez une émeute et
vous ne pouvez de toutes les façons par
entrer ça commence à mettre en place à
en paca avons dit en ile-de-france mans
il faut pas y compter
après ça dépend des lieux et ça dépend
des situations nous en ile de france
ça ne servirait à rien pourquoi mais je
vous donnerai simplement l'explication
c'est que à châtelet ou mettre des
portiques qui ont beau livre est
complètement la gare du châtelet mais à
côté de ça vous avez un réseau maillé de
de centaines de gares donc la vérité
c'est qu'il suffirait de monter dans une
petite gare de banlieue et à ce moment
là on aurait pas de portiques donc la
vérité c'est que le portique n'est pas
une panacée en matière de sécurité en
revanche il ya deux choses qui sont très
importantes
c'est la présence humaine et c'est la
vidéoprotection avec des personnes qui
derrière la vidéo en direct sur est ce
qui se passe mais il ya aussi des outils
un peu plus technologique par exemple
d'aider des détecteurs d'armes qui sont
pas forcément sportif sous lesquelles on
masse mais qu'ils peuvent
on a des outils qui peuvent détecter
quand on passe devant donc en fait on en
voulez vous à les accélérer faire de
tous ces mois là l'idée c'est d'avoir du
matériel qui à certains points
stratégiques et sans que évidemment les
terroristes ne le sache pourrait
détecter encore des choses et nous
permettent d'avoir du renseignement
comment ça se passe avec le ministre de
l'intérieur il ya une volonté bien sûr
commune d'aborder de front les sujets
oui alors le ministre de l'intérieur lui
à une meilleure connaissance et qui est
en charge
mais sur l'île de france mon message a
été simple c'est que je souhaitais que
les 400 policiers et militaires
supplémentaires qui aujourd'hui sont
déployés sur la région sur le réseau
francilien puisse être aussi déployés
dans les gares de grande couronne qu'on
n'ait pas le sentiment qui a finalement
une sécurité à deux vitesses d'abord une
sécurité dans le métro dans le coeur de
paris et que en réalité tout le reste du
réseau soit oubliée donc il m'a garanti
qu'effectivement il y aurait les
patrouilles dans les trains et dans les
gares
y compris sur le réseau de cambronne
alors l'idée c'est évidemment on peut
pas tout surveiller tout le temps au
même moment
mais l'idée c'est de faire de procéder
par sonde de faire des contrôles
d'identité j'allais dire aléatoire et
moi je suis très heureuse parce que ça
fait un petit moment que je demande
qu'on puisse procéder à ces contrôles
d'identité dans le kit dans le dans les
transports en commun donc aujourd'hui il
faut pour prendre les transports en
commun pouvoir justifier de son identité
vous savez que c'est la loi savary qui
devrait être promulguée dans les jours
qui viennent
nous attendons vraiment que le présent
la république la première est vite et
que les décrets d'application de cette
loi soit pris très vite cette prise de
conscience quant à la fermeté nécessaire
aujourd'hui pour répondre vous l'avez
senti auprès des autorités de l'exécutif
aujourd'hui oui mais vous voyez quand
j'apprends à ma grande stupéfaction cet
après midi que le fichier ce qu'on
appelle le personal name ricort de vieux
fichiers des déplacements en avion en
europe mais toujours pas mis en place
parce que les députés européens n'ont
pas réussi à se mettre d'accord je me
dis mais qu'est ce que c'est que cet
aveuglement comment est-ce qu'on peut
après le 13 mai pas de l'expression de
bernard cazeneuve réclame avec force ce
vol ans on était décalés dans le temps
ce bien sûr mais là aussi j'appelle à la
responsabilité
on sait que si celui-ci ce fichier n'a
pas été approuvé c'est parce que il ya
une espèce d'alliance contre nature du
front national et j'allais dire des
populistes européens avec une partie de
la gauche l'antique on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui même si on certains pays
n'ont pas été frappés ils doivent être
solidaires de ceux qui le sont
aujourd'hui
et là vraiment je pousse un cri enfin
l'europe pourra réagir
on peut pas être un ventre mou sinon
c'est toute l'europe va se désagréger
peut pas être un ventre mou face à la
menace terroriste
on doit être souverain souverain ça veut
dire prendre au parlement européen les
vraies décisions
il n'y a pas que les parlements français
belge parce que sinon ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on va vers le retour des
frontières ça veut dire qu'on va vers la
dislocation de l'europe c'est déjà un
peu le cas aujourd'hui en tous les cas
le retour des frontières il y à un
scénario catastrophe dans lequel
l'europe ne survit pas à une crise
terroristes qui met à l'épreuve sa
fermeté et sa capacité à être souveraine
et à avoir des frontières sûres c'est un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui
enfin vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on a
commis un bond de porte d'entrée avec la
belgique c'est énorme
j'ai beaucoup apprécié la démarche de
bernard cazeneuve je l'appelais pour me
dire qu'est ce que je peux faire de plus
il m'a tout de suite dit venez on va en
parler et on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
de plus ensemble
je pense que l'unité c'est pour l'action
c'est pas uniquement pour des postures
dans ceux où voilà où pour se mettre en
valeur et b si la droite était au
pouvoir par exemple à ce que les choses
seraient différentes il ya une phrase
c'est terrible de marion maréchal-le pen
qui a dit que les lier aux abeilles
d'attentât en france le 13 novembre si
le front national était au pouvoir avait
été au pouvoir comme si on avait réagi à
ce point et puisque la droite ferait
différemment les choses
d'abord c'est une phrase totalement
grotesque c'est d'autant plus grotesque
je vous dis le front national a refusé
de voter le personnel emery cote
le front national a refusé de voter la
loi renseignement le front national a
refusé l'interdiction des sites qui
appelle à l' aile sur internet au nom de
la liberté de pouvoir dire ce qu'on veut
sur internet liberté qu'ils utilisent
abondamment donc la vérité c'est que
aujourd'hui ceux qui sont dans l'action
c'est les partis de gouvernement parce
que c'est ceux qui sont responsables
alors si vous me demandez si je pense qu
on a perdu un peu de temps oui j'ai
trouvé qu'on avait perdu du temps on a
perdu du temps sur la sécurité dans les
transports
moi ça fait des mois et des mois que
j'alerte est et on me disait où vous
êtes en campagne électorale
bon et maintenant il ya une unité et
limité que je dois saluer et c'est
précieux cette unité dans les moments
que nous vivons est donc je ne
critiquerai rien aujourd'hui même si je
vous dis dès janvier 2015
j'avais alerté j'avais demandé qu'on
travaille à un patriot act à la
française ça va péter
on a perdu du temps mais aujourd'hui
l'unité que que nous vivons est trop
précieuse pour qu'on polémique déçu
est-ce qu'on a perdu du temps également
dans certains territoires de la
république et notamment d'île de france
selon vous valérie pécresse
est ce qu'il y a des mullen bec aux
portes de paris
je crois que la situation mais je n'ai
pas la nôtre d'abord parce que nous
avons aujourd'hui en tout cas je
l'espère vraiment pris la mesure du
danger qui nous menace et nous avons une
action qui aujourd'hui de 2,2 on a fermé
des mosquées des mosquées qui appelait à
la haine on en a fermé en ile de france
on a fermé la mosquée de lagny sur marne
seine et marne il ya toujours le budget
communautarisme salafistes vous l'avez
dénoncé durant votre campagne
oui moi ce que je crois c'est que aucune
capitale européenne et la france
l'île de france est une capitale très
cosmopolite aucune capitale européenne
n'est à l'abri de foyers de
radicalisation nous avons en
ile-de-france des foyers de
radicalisation nous le savons et nous
devons lutter contre et nous devons
lutter contre alors j'allais dire ça
mais l'éditeur est ce que vous vous
adressez à certaine complaisance
politique dans certaines municipalités
par exemple on a pu peut-être par
lâcheté ou naïveté fermer les yeux et il
y en a certainement eu de la lâcheté
dabo jour d'hui aujourd'hui dans
certaines villes bah écoutez moi je vais
vous donner un seul exemple lors c'est
un petit exemple mais pour moi il est il
très symbolique je suis une femme vous
comprendrez que c'est pour moi
symbolique le fait qu' on puisse
aujourd'hui à voir des femmes en voile
intégral sur le sol de de l'île de
france dans des banlieues
c'est un signe de provocation c'est le
premier 6000 est totalement visible
l'uniforme de radiation de la loire je
ne réclame pas seulement ça la pure la
loi ou d'abord je réclame l'application
la loi mais ça c'est minime mais il
serait longue mais surtout qu'on mette
n'ai pu me dire que j'ai pu lire y
compris dans la presse parce que c'était
les
les cinq ans l'interdiction ou les dix
ans et 5 ans l'interdiction de la burqa
sur le sol
le seul français que j'ai pu lire que ce
n'était pas un sujet alors que c'est un
signe visible extérieure d'un début de
radicalisation ada début de coupure
vis-à-vis du foeil républicain donc en
réalité au lieu de prendre ce voile
intégral pour ce qu'il est c'est à dire
une forme de dérive dans laquelle on
estime que la loi de sa religion est
plus forte que la loi de son pays parce
que c'est ça parce que ça traduit et
bien au lieu de prendre ça comme un
signal d'alarmé
on a fermé les yeux on a détourné la
tête et on n'a pas voulu voir
oui il ya eu la lâcheté il ya eu la
lâcheté il y en a encore et il faut pas
aujourd'hui vous aimez l'action là sur
ce terrain là moi je dis d'ailleurs des
choses là mais moi je pense je crois
qu'une partie de mon élection en
décembre vient du fait que j'ai dit un
certain nombre de choses que je serai
une républicaine intransigeant que je
couperai toutes les subventions
régionales aux associations dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de respect des
principes de la république de la laïcité
de l'égalité hommes femmes que j'ai dit
que nous irions vérifier dans les
sociétés de transport mais aussi dans
les services publics qui dépendent de la
région qu'il n'y a pas de personnes en
voie de radicalisation au contact des
usagers au contact dans les sociétés de
transport dans les lycées donc tout ce
que j'ai dit dans la campagne je pense à
le mettre en oeuvre
on le met en oeuvre on est en train de
travailler sur une charte de la laïcité
pour toutes les associations
subventionnées par la région parce que
nous avons un problème nous avons un
problème de laïcité dans un certain
nombre d'associations sportives ou d'un
nombre d'établissements scolaires où il
ya des pressions à la fois
communautariste et j'allais dire
intégrer
la déchéance de nationalité maintenant
elle a du plomb dans l'oeil vous avez vu
après le vote et à quelques instants du
sénat qui a réécrit le texte issu du
compromis laborieux de l'assemblée
nationale entre la droite et la gauche
est ce que vous le regrettez la position
est simple je pense que ce texte n'a pas
sa place dans la constitution la
déchéance de nationalité n'a pas sa
place dans la constitution pourquoi
parce que je suis favorable à des
sanctions exemplaires contre le
terrorisme mais dans la constitution qui
est notre loi fondamentale qu'on puisse
faire la distinction entre deux types de
français ça me choque les sénateurs les
républicains ont proposé de décider
d'une peine de prison perpétuelle la
perpétuité perpétuelle qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
sans possibilité de remise est ce que
c'est une idée qui vous agréent août
après tout si on pense par exemple à
salah abdeslam de toutes les façons il
ya des peines aujourd'hui de sûreté et
de rétention si une personne qui est
condamné à la perpétuité aujourd'hui
c'est à dire à 20-30 ans de prison ferme
aujourd'hui au moment où il sort s'il
est encore dangereux
oui il ya des rétention de sûreté donc 2
ne doit pas sortir les paquets fermes
l'essai 5 tirs n'existe pas aujourd'hui
dans le cadre du terrorisme et
d'ailleurs manuel valls a dit il ya
quelques instants qu'il était prêt à
étudier cette proposition venue de la
droite on peut tout étudier mais d'une
manière générale je pense qu'il ne faut
pas laisser sortir un terroriste de
prison il faut le retenir
avec une peine de rétention de sûreté
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
y à un certain nombre de personnes qui
ne se sont pas du tout amendé en prison
et donc il faut quand même qu'on
applique la loi telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui avec de la rétention de
sûreté
parce que la peine que le sénat va lui
proposer elle ne s'appliquera qu'à
l'avenir
c'est là qu'elle s'appliquera que pour
le futur moi je pense à ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui en prison